hey everybody its skylar astin and i am
taking on BuzzFeed's thirst tweets but
first I'm gonna get the mood just right
what situation isn't you know maybe
better by accessibility on fire so here
we go let's do this I have a two hour
bus ride to a tournament so I'm just
gonna Google pictures of Skylar asked in
the whole time that's so sweet
maybe this should be called wholesome
tweets what did we come up with on those
image searches there's some stuff from
pitch perfect maybe a weird hair style
from Spring Awakening we're not getting
too thirsty yet but I have been naked in
a movie finally started watching Zoe's
extraordinary playlist and my massive
crush on Skylar Astin has officially
been revived well I'm so sorry that it
died maybe there was a point in my
career where I just got a little like a
little bloated you could say it the
number one reason I watch pitch perfect
is to stare at skylar astin arms and
lips thank you so much for saying so how
was my acting Skylar Astin zaps that's
it that's the tweet hashtag Zoe's
playlist thank you I did so many
crunches for that scene it was
embarrassing Skylar Astin is hotter than
the bottom of my laptop that's clever
Skylar Astin can destroy me and I would
ask for seconds thirds and fourth
helpings at the buffet no comment I
can't comment on that I have the meanest
toner for Skylar Astin
that's very sweet I like when the pitch
perfect lexicon makes its way to real
life maybe this should be called meta
tweets or maybe I should stop trying to
retitle this okay
I love Skylar essence but okay bye sure
sustained to the point we like that I
want to kiss Skylar asked him so badly
ah he makes me sexually frustrated I
hate that the only answer to your
problem is kiss I can't do that I'm
social distancing I like Skylar Astin
more than 21 and over then in pitch
perfect because he makes out with a guy
and wears nothing but a tube sock over
his [ __ ] he was very true my first and
only boy kiss miles teller in a scene
from 21 and over where exactly I was I
was where
I was completely full frontal naked and
I just had like a red hot chili pepper
style one stock so check that out Google
search from the first tweet kia ferry
soft lips and that's all i have to say
about that skylar astin smile makes my
ovaries explode how the fanuc does
somebody get that fine tears of joy I
know this just seems like it's going
through fright to the ego but who
doesn't want like some compliments like
that every once in a while
Skyler asked who makes my vagina throb
not just my heart Skyy laughs - Skyy
laughs - Skylar and Skylar us - Skylar
Astin hots gather us and hot Skylar
Astin amazingly hot Skylar Astin hop you
should try punctuation I've been
thinking about this a lot and I've
decided that I would definitely let
Skylar Astin take my butthole virginity
well that's a two-way street sista
warning I got a warning on this tweet
cuz it's the last one I'll sing it guys
thank you so much for joining me on
BuzzFeed's thirsty tweets even though I
know it's called thirst tweets
[Music]
[Music]